hi
hi I am
a different Christian
[Music]
hi hello uh my name is Christian if
you're new here and if you're not then
you already know that as of this may I
will have been living on the road full
time for five years this journey began
for me in 2013 when I left the corporate
world to spend some time backpacking
internationally and I eventually landed
in Big Sur California and that's where I
slowly began to build my career as an
outdoor adventure photographer four
years later I found myself living in
Seattle and my apartment lease was about
to end I made the decision to donate
sell or store pretty much all of my
belongings and I moved into my SUV it
was a Nissan Xterra it was only supposed
to be a summer experiment
but I wound up falling madly in love
with the road and
I stayed in my SUV for 14 months before
deciding to invest in this custom build
ban which has been my home for almost
four years now officially I haven't had
an actual apartment or home to call my
own since May of 2018 which is still
pretty wild to me like it was never
supposed to go this long a couple years
ago I put together a video called 10
tips for getting started in Van life
where I went to a lot of detail about my
journey and some practical tips for
getting started with this lifestyle I'll
touch on a few of those things in this
video
um as well as some points I made in my
10 reasons why van life sucks video but
I also want to bypass some of the more
obvious points and dive into some more
personal thoughts on like deeper topics
I mentioned in a previous video that I
want to start experimenting and trying
some new things and that's kind of what
I'm hoping to do here and in future
talking videos I just want to start
conversations and share knowledge that
I've gained over the years based on my
own experiences with this lifestyle in
hopes of offering some value to those of
you who are interested in taking a
similar path this might be a bit of a
ramble I I don't know I'm just gonna try
it and y'all let me know what you think
in the comments below I guess so let's
dive in why the heck would anyone ever
want to live in a van you have to be
pretty passionate about this way of life
or at least your reason for doing it to
actually enjoy it for any real length of
time yes it can be adventurous uh it can
be beautiful it can be liberating it can
be all of those things 100 percent
however it can also be incredibly
challenging isolating growth and weird
ask yourself really like why do you want
to do this
is it to save money by not paying rent
is it to travel full-time and see the
country are you craving Freedom or fresh
start or did you maybe see pretty photos
on Instagram or dreamy scenes on Youtube
and decide this is the life for you I
can tell you why I pursued this
lifestyle my five-year relationship had
just Fallen apart I really wanted a
fresh start I didn't want to throw money
away on rent and I was craving new
adventures and frankly I just got tired
of driving back and forth to my
apartment to swap out gear and do
laundry I was still trying to build my
career as an outdoor adventure
photographer and living on the road
actually facilitated and supported that
path because it allowed me to expand my
portfolio by traveling to all sorts of
Landscapes and spending two to three
weeks in a singular location rather than
just like one or two days and then
having to pick up and go and that
allowed me to witness different weather
and lighting conditions and that's how
really get the best shots so for me it
made sense
now I'm at a point where I'm beginning
to ask myself if it still makes sense
I've been doing this for so long now
that I'm kind of just ready to try new
things that's kind of an evolving
thought process right now and we'll save
that for another video last year I put
together a video titled 10 reasons why
van life sucks
and I cannot tell you how many comments
I receive saying something to the effect
of duh tell me something I don't know
and as someone who has lived in both a
van and an SUV I can say that in my
experience people leaned more toward
enthusiasm whenever I showed them the
van but borderline concern when I'd show
them my sleeping setup in the SUV not
everyone of course but generally
speaking in other words there's
there's quite a bit of stigma
surrounding this lifestyle and sadly it
can oftentimes be Amplified depending on
the condition and cleanliness of your
vehicle I mean we all kind of know that
already right like it's pretty much the
same when it comes to actual housing
like who has the bigger house or who has
the better car or whatever there are
some pretty strong opinions out there
that all van lifers are drain on society
or a bunch of rich kids just living off
of trust funds or Worse glorifying
homelessness and this is something that
I want to touch on briefly because I
have kind of a nuanced perspective on
this
my mom had me when she had just turned
17 and we jumped from place to place we
lived with my grandparents we lived in a
basement guest bedrooms her car I know
what it's like at least as a child to
not have a home when that's really all
that you want and there are so many
people especially today who are living
in vehicles by circumstance and not by
choice I think that sometimes it's easy
to generalize people who live in their
vehicles as a certain kind of person
depending on the way that you see the
world there is a subset of people who
view this lifestyle as a stain on
society like it's something that you
should be ashamed of to be very open and
honest my biological father is one of
those people
when I moved onto the road he made it
very clear that he viewed my decision to
live in an SUV as shameful irresponsible
and embarrassing and as far as I know he
still feels that way I am incredibly
fortunate that the rest of my family and
also my friends have been supportive and
encouraging as I've wandered down this
path but I know that might not be your
situation so I share this for those of
you who maybe don't have the support and
encouragement that you deserve and I
hope that in spite of that you'll still
allow yourself to dream and just
personally Define what it is that you
want and what skills and Gifts you have
to offer the world and whether or not
this lifestyle can help you get there
sometimes what we really need is just
time especially when it comes to
creative Endeavors and if eliminating a
monthly rent payment can easier
financial responsibilities just enough
that
it frees up your time and energy to
focus elsewhere be that school or work
or like learning a new skill then that
alone might be worth it just be aware
and prepare yourself for potential
labels and judgments to be cast your way
honestly the best advice I can offer to
prepare for those moments that you might
encounter out on the road are just to
remind yourself why you wanted this in
the first place and if you have that
deep sense of self and knowing then you
know
that's all you really need easier said
than done though I personally am accused
of being a trust fund baby on a fairly
regular basis which honestly if there is
a trust fund out there with my name on
it I will take it I'd love to know I
unfortunately am not a trust fund baby I
also do not have a sugar daddy unless we
count you the viewers who so kindly
watch my videos and support my
sponsorships
I want to take a quick minute to thank
today's sponsor ag1 I've been using ag1
for three months now and it's actually
the first time that I've been consistent
in sticking with a vitamin routine for
more than a week living on the road can
sometimes mean limited access to food
variety and storage and ag-1 helps to
bridge any of those nutritional gaps in
my diet it's become an easy and
effortless part of my routine which has
actually inspired me to Habit stack and
Implement other positive changes like
regular exercise cutting back on sugar
and daily meditation station I
personally like to drink my ag1 in the
morning or before my first meal and I
genuinely love the taste of it there's
no added sugar but it still has this
perfect sweet taste so guys be sure to
check out 81 using my link here below to
support my channel and more importantly
just to try it out for yourself I am
really curious to hear what you think
and if you love it as much as I do so
thank you ag1 for sponsoring this video
and let's get into it once you've
figured out your why
you've got to try it out and this could
be as simple as tossing a blow up
camping mattress in your back seat or as
specific as renting your dream rig and
taking it out for a couple weeks if you
don't have a vehicle that you can sleep
in consider buying a camping tent and
using that to sleep in pretty much every
night you know like it's gonna limit
your experience in terms of where you
can sleep but you'll still get a really
decent understanding of what it's like
to live in a small space and with
minimal conveniences I would really
recommend that you spend at least two
weeks out on the road and see how that
goes
also say try to resist the urge to stay
at a bunch of paid campsites and make
sure you're spending at least some of
that time alone this stuff is really
really important because after two weeks
You're Gonna Know fairly well whether or
not you love it or you hate it allow me
to illustrate
[Music]
I've been flirting with the idea of
bangs I wound up buying fake bangs on
Amazon instead to just like test them
out
I don't have a mirror I have no idea how
this looks I don't know what do we think
bangs are no big okay I'm back boring me
no bangs version you guys get what I'm
putting down right like test it before
you buy it and testing out this
lifestyle first is also going to help
you understand what kind of rig to
invest in like do you want an SUV do you
want a used van do you want a new van a
schooly an RV Do you want to build it
yourself do you want to hire a team to
do it
is it possible that you can make your
current vehicle work doesn't need a
dedicate a workspace or will you need a
massive power supply well you have a
surfboard or mountain bikes or a pet how
are you going to shower how will you use
the bathroom and how will you cook on
the road so apart from overnight parking
these are the three almost daily hurdles
that you're going to face when living in
a vehicle for showers I rely on gym
memberships campgrounds I have a solar
bag uh and truck stops are an option but
to be honest I've still actually never
used one in all of my years on the road
they're 15 and I just think that's
really expensive because the gym
membership is like thirty dollars for a
whole month that's just my opinion when
I lived in the SUV I didn't have any
kind of toilet and when I moved into the
van I had a number one only toilet for I
guess three years and it's only in like
recently last summer that I got a
composting toilet and
I cannot recommend it enough let's talk
about food it's a great segue when it
comes to cooking it's important to
consider your normal eating habits and
how living on the road might impact them
especially if you like to eat a lot of
fresh vegetables and or cook you might
want to invest in a cooler or fridge or
stove and there are a ton of options
um but I will say that maintaining some
level of familiarity and normality will
help you stay grounded and like feeling
healthy
so all of these things together will be
really helpful in determining what kind
of rig you're working towards so that
you can move to the next question which
is can you afford this a common
misconception is that van life is cheap
and yes there is a spectrum it can be
cheap but the way I look at it uh the
major savings is your monthly rent slash
mortgage payment but from that savings
you need to consider new expenses like
maybe a vehicle loan Park and Campground
fees the occasional hotel or Airbnb stay
showers laundry unexpected repairs
maintenance mail forwarding Services
storage unit rental fees out of pocket
dental and doctor appointments if you
don't have nationwide health insurance
or any health insurance also ask
yourself
are you able to part with most of the
things in your home because living in a
van that feels like an overstuffed
closet can be a claustrophobic
experience and I don't recommend it
unless you're retired or you have a way
of funding your travels indefinitely
you're also going to want to think about
how you'll sustain your travels some
people travel short term and live off
their savings While others work remotely
I personally am a freelance photographer
and videographer
um so that's how I earned my income on
the road and there are so many ways to
work remotely I actually did put
together a video about that um I'll link
it up here 10 ways to work remotely or
something like that
um but the conversation doesn't really
end there because working for yourself
it sounds really wonderful and like
don't get me wrong it is I love it I you
know I work for myself I've been doing
it for a long time and I absolutely
would not trade it for anything
but it is a big adjustment from working
for an employer or even from working in
a stationary office in your home imagine
that your park at the edge of the Grand
Canyon and it's just beautiful outside
but you have a deadline and so you have
to sit inside your van stare at your
computer screen and put together a
spreadsheet not that big of a deal right
but now imagine having to do that five
days a week
always someplace new and beautiful that
you'd rather go explore it's kind of
like someone putting a plate of fresh
baked cookies in front of your face
alongside a plate of raw broccoli and
you have to find the willpower to eat
the broccoli instead of the cookies
every single day for me personally I've
found that willpower is a limited
resource and working remotely in
beautiful places requires a lot of it
that's just been my experience hopefully
yours will be different now I want to
address everyone's favorite question
but doesn't it get lonely out there on
the road
yes
yes it does
absolutely
it also gets lonely in a house
with a mouse loneliness can happen
anywhere to anyone with anyone
that said living on the road is uniquely
different like our society is not
conducive to this way of living and as a
result you can start to feel a little
adrift and disconnected from The Real
World like you're living on The Fringe
and maybe a bit of an outcast I have
personally felt this more in the past
year than ever before
but you know I think that's because I
was going through a breakup I was really
focused on a lot of personal growth and
I just didn't want to be around people I
just wanted to be alone like alone alone
like a little lady living on a mountain
who never comes down alone thankfully
those clouds began to part months ago
but the overall effect was one of
extreme disconnectedness
and as an introvert I'm pretty
comfortable in that zone but I have
discovered that it does have its limits
if you're also an introvert and looking
into this lifestyle
beware the pitfall of becoming too
isolated on the road it's so easy to
avoid people if you want to or literally
like turtles in our little houses on our
backs and it's so comfortable and
familiar to just curl up inside our
little forts on Wheels and hide away
from the world and add to that the fact
that you're less likely to bump into
someone you know at a coffee shop in a
city that you're only passing through or
meet up with friends at like a weekly
CrossFit class because you're rarely in
one place long enough to actually become
a regular or even to just like see
someone you know while out walking your
dog the beauty of living mobile is that
the pendulum can swing wildly from an
introvert's Paradise to an extrovert
stream it really is very customizable
but you have to be really intentional
about it and if you're an extrovert I
can't help you I have learned
extroverted Tendencies but I am an
introvert through and through however I
will say that there are so many cool
people out there in this community who
are also Road lifers or just genuinely
interested in this lifestyle and
I get the impression that if you just
open your side door for a while and like
sit outside chances are you'll make a
new friend before the day is done
but you know I can't really speak on
that because I tend to hide
like a weirdo a lack of community in
combination with bouts of loneliness can
really start to weigh on you but this
doesn't just apply to Van life like you
can find yourself in a similar situation
like I said by living in a house or an
apartment and the thing to understand is
that the road doesn't have built-in
conveniences or community in the way
that most modern societies do and so
most things are going to require an
extra level of effort and your job is
really to determine if that extra effort
is worth the trade-offs of living on the
road sometimes the things we love about
the road over time become the things
that challenge us the most having
routines for example like I love that I
wake up and decide that day what it is I
feel like doing I love the freedom of
hold on
so there's I love the freedom to just
pick up and go like it's fun it's
exciting it's kind of a dopamine hit
that I've unfortunately become
accustomed to at this point but that
same lack of routine causes me all kinds
of stress as well for example waking up
somewhere new every day means constantly
navigating on familiar roads and
educating myself on state laws and local
ordinances and understanding where I can
and can't legally park overnight I
mentioned a while back that I was pulled
over for a speeding ticket in Arizona
for going 55 okay 60. on what I thought
was a 55 Road this cop pulled out about
two minutes after I'd pulled out from my
camping spot I hadn't even passed a
speed limit sign at that point and he
gave me a ticket for going 55 in a 45
Zone but not before saying first that
the speed limit turns to 55 in another
mile and then people get confused all
the time
like that's a hundred thirty dollars I
wouldn't have had to pay if I had just
lived in that area and known that
I'm still annoyed by that things like
doctor and dentist appointments having a
car mechanic you always go to a
hairstylist you love a cafe that you
prefer those things are tough to
maintain when you're constantly moving
around and in my experience they can
actually prove kind of costly because
you're relying on trial and error to
find people you trust in various new
cities like all the time now if your
plan is to have a home base of your own
or maybe return to your parents house a
couple times every year to run all these
errands that's perfect if you're like me
and your parents live in the eastern U.S
it will get kind of exhausting driving
44 hours each way every time you need
your teeth cleaned and your oil change
this leads me to the next point of
figuring out how you'll receive mail
vote and pay taxes
this has to be one of the single
greatest headaches for me personally
during my five years on the road in the
state of Washington it's legal to live
in an RV so luckily I've been able to
register my vehicle and get a driver's
license and a few other things using a
private mailbox which I renew every few
months however I have been reluctant to
share this in the past because I don't
know how legal this is
um but running a business from a private
mailbox is tricky I've had countless
calls with the Washington Department of
Revenue explaining my situation because
as a small business owner I'm
responsible for paying quarterly
business and occupation tax and they
have told me yes of course I must pay it
but I have to actually live at the
address that I use
so it's like
I can either use this private mailbox
address that I don't live at or I can
just not pay my taxes so obviously I
choose to pay my taxes but it sucks
feeling like an outlaw just for existing
as a road lifer another recent example
this has to do with banking which by the
way before you move on to the road and
while you still have a legal address
I would urge you urge you to open any
necessary bank accounts or credit cards
that you intend to use renew your
passport and driver's license open your
private mailbox get insurance and
register your vehicle
after doing my taxes this past year I
decided to open a self-employed Ira
because up to that point my only
retirement was a 401K with my former
employer and I was no longer able to
deposit funds there since I don't work
there anymore
so I called that bank to inquire about
opening an account and they walked me
through everything
only to have it turned down at the end
of the process because my address was a
private mailbox
so then I called two of my other Banks
and ran into the same exact issue all I
wanted to do was literally give these
Banks my money and they were treating me
like some kind of criminal because I
don't live in an actual house to be fair
like every customer service rep I spoke
with was incredibly kind really
sympathetic to my living situation but I
mean the institutions themselves the
society that we live in it practically
punishes People Like Us who choose to
live outside the lines
and this is kind of becoming a mini rant
because I also get a fair amount of
comments claiming that van lifers don't
pay taxes which trust me we do I
personally pay far more taxes now than I
did when I was living in a house working
a corporate job and I just have to
wonder like what the heck why is it that
Society is so insistent that we all live
exactly like one another
why are you the way that you are okay I
think that's a good place to end this
video
no not really I still have quite a few
other topics to cover including health
insurance overnight parking
bathroom things all of that good stuff
and I'm gonna work on putting that
together for you guys
um like a part two of this video I think
ideally it would be cool to have these
more casual commentary type videos so if
you can call them that
um on a somewhat weekly basis if I can
stick to that and keep the vlogging
videos on the regular once a month
schedule because those other videos take
a lot of time to shoot and edit and I
like them to have kind of a dream like
quality
because it's my creative Outlet it's my
art obviously you guys know that I love
this lifestyle it's easily been one of
the best decisions I've ever made
but there's also this other side of Van
life that is also very real and
sometimes overlooked and like hard to
integrate into my other artistic work
and I don't know I just think it might
be interesting to chat about this stuff
so that's it for this video stay tuned
for part two if you enjoyed this one
um thank you so much for being here I
really really appreciate you guys thank
you for all of your support and kind
comments and yeah I will see you soon
I really just went to the camera oh my
God
[Music]
foreign